we have discussed the possibility of
violence tonight and
into the week uh the white house is
taking it seriously they've built a new
fence around the white house to protect
donald trump we'll talk about that later
other countries as i've already told you
taking it seriously issuing travel
warnings for their citizens who plan to
be in the united states
i gave you the examples of australia and
new zealand and there are others
college as i mentioned george washington
university in dc telling students
plan like it's a snowstorm where you
might not be able to or might not want
to go out for days
stockpile food stockpile medication okay
reporters for reuters covering today's
election
will have protective gear in
anticipation
of unrest after a bunch of incidents in
which journalists were targeted during
summer
protests reporters are being given
flak jackets helmets and gas masks
plus because we have a global pandemic
all of the ppe
that you would need from the public
health standpoint now i want to be
really clear about one thing
tonight and this week there is concern
about
armed trumpists and generally about
voters
being out in large angry groups and of
course
that's a concern but remember that
during the anti-police brutality
protests over the summer
most incidents of police or rather i'm
sorry
i'm getting ahead of myself most
incidents of press
being attacked hit by rubber bullets
knocked down punched
it was mostly coming at the hands of
police and not protesters
that has been the big risk the reason it
might change tonight
and this week is that donald trump has
been very hostile to the media for four
years now
he has been attacking the media as fake
and phony and bad people and the enemy
of the people
trumpists often will verbally abuse
reporters at trump's rallies many
stories about that
and the idea is if trump narrowly loses
and claims it was rigged
you are going to see the possibility of
escalation into physical violence
against the media
who many trump is again see as the enemy
that is legitimate and i would be
worried about that but
again reminder until now the biggest
risk to the press
at protests has been police officers
beating reporters
um rubber bullets from armed officers
hitting reporters not danger from
actual protesters now can we step back
for just a second
and appreciate how insane this headline
is
reuters equipping journalists covering
the u.s
election with flak jackets helmets
and gas masks election reporters in the
u.s
are having to be prepared like war
correspondents
this is where america is in 2020.
other countries have offered to send us
election monitors and in fact have sent
them to 28 states there are 11
states in the u.s where such observers
are banned
including many states in the south of
the united states
i know four years is a long time change
happens slowly
we have slowly become desensitized to
these changes crazy things have become
normalized but step
back for a moment and consider how
insane it is
that reporters need protective gear to
cover
a u.s election because of the threat of
violence
as the president has said he will go to
courts to try to get
mail-in ballots thrown out won't commit
to a peaceful transfer of power
while saying if he loses he may leave
the country like a deposed
authoritarian dictator trump wants to be
afraid
of some non-existent hypothetical
biden's america
but look at trump's america right now
trump at his rallies continues to say if
you vote for biden it's a vote for
anarchy
or anarchy as he says if you vote for
biden it's a vote for
low water pressure and no heating in the
winter no cooling in the summer
having to flush your toilet 10 or 15
times
the end of the suburb all of this
different stuff trump has been painting
a completely dystopian picture
if don if joe biden were to win but
remember
donald trump is president now look at
the list of things that are happening
now
that many of us would never ever ever
have imagined would have been
what the united states is like if i and
again
to frame this go back to november
what was it november 9th of 2016
the day after the election if i had told
you
four years from now this laundry list of
things will be happening in the united
states i don't think any of you would
have believed it very very few of you
would have believed it
that is where we are today let's
[Music]
de-desensitize
let's re-sensitize ourselves to the
insanity of this
uh and let's hope that tonight we see uh
the right results i hope you'll join me
i will be live
on youtube twitch and facebook starting
just shy of 7 p.m eastern time make sure
you're also following the david pakman
show on
instagram at david pakman show